Hour one.
There is only one news story, on every website,
newspaper, and TV screen.
The flowers are blooming everywhere, all across
the globe.
Every country, every landmass.
The bitter cold of the Antarctic gives way
to a glowing rainbow of petals.
The Sahara Desert and Death Valley become
beacons of thriving technicolor plantlife.
The highest mountains, the lowest valleys,
the darkest caves.
The flowers even burst free from the concrete
of cities, as if reminding us that really,
it was never our world, we were only borrowing
it.
And today, our lease is up.
This is SCP-001.
Object Class: Unnecessary.
It was foretold by tales from other dimensions,
a distant future coming down the tracks towards
us.
And today, the train has reached the station.
Nobody’s reporting on how the economy or
the stock market is doing today.
No point.
Celebrity scandals have
faded away into nothingness.
Greedy businessmen, lying politicians, brutal
tyrants.
None of them are making the headlines today.
The very last headlines.
The World’s Gone Beautiful.
And what a shame it takes the end of it all
to make us realize what really matters to
us.
That’s right: You’re looking at the end
of the world.
But it’s okay.
Don’t panic.
Take a deep breath, in and out.
It was bound to happen eventually, so no point
worrying now.
Even the Foundation knows that this just isn’t
something they can stop.
So instead of asking things like, “How can
we prevent this?” or “Do we have any final
tricks up our sleeve?”
let’s ask a different question entirely:
“What would you do if you knew that you
only had 24 hours until all life on earth
ends?”
Think hard.
After all, even if you never live to see the
flowers bloom, a final day will still come
for you, just as it does for us all.
Hour six.
A D-Class sits alone in his cell when he sees
the flowers growing out of the ground.
Normally, he’d assume this meant he was
in some kind of Foundation experiment.
But not today.
Everyone on earth has an innate sense that
the time is now.
A kind of gallows calm spreads out over everyone
and everything.
It’s over, and that’s okay.
We all knew it was going to happen eventually,
right?
He sighs and gives a slight smile.
Those flowers sure are beautiful.
That’s when he hears footsteps outside his
cell, approaching.
A key slides into his cell door, and it opens.
There stands Dr. Gears, holding a bottle of
wine and two glasses.
Anyone who knows him might think he’s been
replaced by some kind of shapeshifting anomaly
or had his mind taken over
by a powerful cognitohazard.
But no.
It’s him.
The famously cold Dr. Charles Ogden Gears.
Dr. Gears says, “Come on.
It’s a lovely day out there.
It’d be a terrible waste to spend the whole
thing cooped up in here.”
It’d feel like a trick, on any day but this.
The D-Class nods and follows the doctor out.
The normally oh-so-stoic Foundation senior
researcher pours himself and the D-Class each
a glass of wine, and asks, “What’s your
name, by the way?
I don’t think I ever checked.”
The D-Class replies that his name is Harold.
The two smile and chat as they exit the now
empty D-Class containment wing.
Everyone else is outside already.
Researchers, guards, administrative staff,
and D-Classes, all rubbing elbows, enjoying
the beautiful sun on their last day together.
Elsewhere on the site, a flock of SCP-514
is released, just as identical flocks are
being released from every containment site
all over the world.
They’ve prepared it all for this very day.
SCP-514 is a special breed of homing pigeons
created by the Manna Charitable Foundation,
which have the power to suppress aggression
for those within their field of anomalous
influence.
And now, millions of them are flying all over
the world.
After all, there’s no point fighting on
a day like this.
There is no future left to secure.
People always told them there would forever
be hope until the flowers bloomed.
No situation was ever truly over until the
world went beautiful.
But in the absence of hope, there was something
even more inviting: Total, absolute calm.
The Site-19 personnel sit together and watch
the flowers bloom.
Hour Twelve.
All militaries call a global ceasefire.
Soldiers from opposing sides hug and shake
hands in flowery fields that once seemed choked
by death and blood.
Borders fade; bitter rivalries turn to dust.
Korea unifies.
All is quiet in the Middle East.
Gangsters and drug cartels drop their weapons
and return home to their families and friends
as flocks of SCP-514 fly above.
What good is all the blood money in the world
on a day like this?
Wardens walk cell to cell through all the
world’s prisons, granting people their freedom
again, sometimes after lifetimes of not having
it.
They taste the air again.
Feel the sun on their face.
They close their eyes, drink it in, and walk
among the flowers.
Free men.
Locations of Marshall, Carter, and Dark Ltd.
close their doors and shutter their windows
worldwide.
For the first time in as long as any of them
can remember, they turn their signs to “Closed.”
They’ve earned a day off.
Everyone has.
The Chaos Insurgency rolls up their plans
and burns them.
They drop their weapons and throw away their
tactical gear.
As they do so, they can’t help but question
themselves: What was it all for, in the end?
What was any of it for?
All the fighting and bloodshed and death?
We did it day after day, only to do it again
the next day.
What silly reasons we killed and died for.
What silly reasons indeed.
The Global Occult Coalition dismisses its
staff, thanking them for their service and
telling them to go spend their last hours
with the ones they love.
Like the Foundation, they accept that this
is the one true, final end.
No ritual to stop, no monster to fight, no
evil extra-dimensional entity to thwart.
Just go outside and smell the flowers, while
you still can.
The Serpent’s Hand are similar.
They decide, after decades fighting a losing
battle, they’ll spend their last day in
the Wanderer’s Library, reading some of
their favorite volumes.
All these wonderful stories, now left for
other earths to read.
Their own stories would be counted among them
in the end, and they take great comfort in
that.
In a sense, everyone will live forever in
the pages of the books in the Wanderer’s
Library.
Herman Fuller’s Circus of the Disquieting
releases all of its freaks and clowns from
their twisted grasp, to go and live out whatever
small dreams and tiny pleasures they could
find over their last hours.
They have no Foundation to fear anymore.
Nobody minds their strange appearances and
odd behaviors.
Why would anyone waste such a beautiful day
judging others?
On the last day on earth, there’s nothing
left to prove.
Sarkicists drop their ancient, flesh-bound
tomes, and acolytes of the Broken God put
down their gilded blades.
On the slopes of Siberia, the jungles of Peru,
and the most isolated beaches of Mexico, twisted
flesh finally touch living metal in the spirit
of husbandry.
Their eternal war is at its end.
In the face of the blooming world, they didn’t
seem so different after all.
The agents of the Dr. Wondertainment corporation,
predictably, choose to spend their last hours
sitting around and playing with toys together.
Time well spent, if you ask us.
In a highly secretive location, perhaps the
most heavily secured place in the entire world,
the thirteen members of the legendary O5 Council
decide to just sit and talk.
As anyone who knows anything about this secretive
cabal can tell you, the O5 Council has spent
a considerable portion of their very, very
long lives trying to figure out ways to dodge
and cheat death.
But now, facing a death they can’t dodge,
the same calm washing over the rest of the
world has finally reached them too.
All they can really think this time is, “Well
played, Reaper, well played” as they chat
about the kind of inane, casual things they
haven’t had the time to discuss in years.
O5-3 suggests inviting the Ethics Committee
over to join.
Nobody disagrees.
Hour sixteen.
It isn’t just the D-Classes.
All sapient and non-aggressive SCPs have been
released from containment, free to spend the
last of their time as they wish.
Tens of thousands of anomalous individuals
are released from containment sites all over
the globe.
It’d be the greatest victory that the Serpent’s
Hand could ever ask for if they weren’t
all too busy reading to notice.
SCP-105, Iris Thompson, finally returns to
her parents.
The Foundation had fed them the lie that their
daughter had died many years before, but as
Iris had a tendency to do, she was ready to
work a miracle.
Her parents embrace her with open arms.
They’ll spend their last hours together
catching up on what’s happened since they
parted ways, and making up for lost time.
They couldn’t be happier.
SCP-1867, Lord Blackwood the fantastical sea
snail, is delivered into a warm rockpool near
the site where he was being contained.
There, he might finally have one more grand
adventure before all is said and done.
Though afterward, he may not have the time
to tell anyone about it.
A terrible shame, really, because nobody spins
a yarn like Lord Blackwood.
The non-aggressive little misters run free.
Mr. Fish eagerly returns to his native Boston,
Massachusetts, where he enjoys one more lobster
sandwich before the end of the world.
Mr. Headless decides to go hat shopping because
he wants to look good for the apocalypse.
Mr. Lost finally settles down for the afternoon,
deciding that, just this once, he’s earned
himself a rest.
SCP-2800, Cactusman, returns to Edinburgh,
to spend his last day picking up litter and
helping old ladies cross the street.
SCP-3663, the Tunnel Monster, walks the streets
of his hometown, searching for an old friend,
hoping to reunite before it all ends.
SCP-073, Cain, decides to take a walk outside
for the first time in thousands of years.
He can’t help but smile, as the bright,
colorful life beneath his feet is growing
faster than his presence can kill it.
What a truly beautiful day.
Knowing that there’s no longer time for
cults to form and bother him, SCP-2662, Cthulhu,
decides to take a break from his intense Minecraft
session and go take a walk outside.
It feels so good to have the sun on his tentacles
once more and to feel lush, green grass under
his suction cups.
He shakes his head, thinking once again about
the irritating cults that had been pestering
him for decades.
What kind of idiot would want him to destroy
a world like this?
SCP-343, also known as God, sighs and looks
over all his creation for what he knows to
be the last time.
His mouth curls into a smile, as he thinks,
“Well, we had a pretty good run.”
Still in his cell, SCP-049, the Plague Doctor,
puts his feet up and decides to relax.
The Pestilence will soon be taken care of.
On some animalistic level, below thought,
below even instinct, SCP-096 feels grateful
that no gaze will ever fall upon it again.
Somewhere, fizzling in a vat of acid within
a highly secure containment chamber, SCP-682
is feeling, for the first time in its hellish
existence, a sense of profound relief.
The pain, the hate, the rage, the constant
termination attempts.
It’d all be over soon.
Hour twenty-three.
People gather in the streets.
They laugh and dance and sing, as the moon
shines, fat and white, far above.
Deep in their hearts, they quietly contemplate
the end of all this.
But why worry?
Why spoil the fun?
There’s no future left to worry about.
Strangers become as close as family in the
end.
Human or otherwise, anomalous or non-anomalous.
Chaos Insurgency agents have last suppers
with ex-Serpent’s Hands and GOC operatives.
There is no hate left.
No violence.
No malice.
No cruelty.
The greatest tragedy in all of this is that
it took the ultimate end to bring it out in
people.
But why worry?
Why worry?
Seconds pass, then minutes.
The world buzzes.
It hums.
Trillions of creatures, doing everything they’d
always wanted, even though they know it won’t
last.
In the face of the true end, the world has
never been more alive.
Hour twenty-four.
Silence.
Forever, and ever, and ever...Goodnight.
We’ll end this video the way it began, by
putting a question to you: How would you spend
your last 24 hours on earth?
Let us know down in the comments.
Because it’ll happen to all of us eventually.
Now go check out “SCP-001 - Which is the
Real 001?” and “SCP-001 Ouroboros Cycle
- The Full Story Compilation” for more journeys
into the surprising and varied world of SCP-001.